hi
and welcome to my talk about pandas and
accessing sql databases
using pandas read and to sql and in this
talk i'm going to show
why it is quite simple to access these
despite the complex
things happening behind the scenes why
it isn't that fast at the moment
how you can get first the alternative
and how we at the end actually can get
it fast by default
before diving now into the actual talk i
want to give you some context about who
i am and why do i
concert with this um i'm a data engineer
at the software data science project
company quantco
um we work with different clients like
different
kinds of data and this data is totally
stored in the
latent database management system
they're quite different so
we have seen quite some of these
challenges
besides my main work or two my main
workout to actually contribute to open
source projects
uh important for this talk i am a
maintainer of apache error
and i'm also making up 2vdbc i do lots
of other open source stuff
but this as a bit of disclaimer because
i will use these technologies in the
talk
um do you think making this fast sensor
or are you getting context why i may be
choosing that
i have a bias because i'm the main
player
um now going back to our talk
the setting we have is that we
like capital mean we have a lot of this
data that has
several columns and each column has an a
and everything in the column
is of the same type
and what python uses we like to do
things in python so we use pandas
in this talk we're actually talking
about large amounts of data large
amounts can start already with 10 000
rows but can go up to a million
um a lot of these things performance why
the show don't make sense for this if
you just
get a single raw result from your
database or so
and on the other side going out of our
pandas bubble python bubble
um the traditional storage system where
you actually would start having your
data where
people in the business modify it is in a
relational database or in a sql database
using it the most common language to
access them
and we're not concerned how do we get
from this traditional sql database or
not always traditional but traditionally
there um
into pandas and once we have done things
and pandas how do we get it back in
again
in panas there are two functions which
are also part of my slide
or my talk title and the first one is
pineapple vdsql
you can use that to read data from an
sql database
into a data frame and there are two main
arguments you need for that the first is
the
sql argument it can be free like to
select start from table
or if you already want to select a full
table
you can just supply the table name you
don't even need to write sql
and the second argument can be an sql
connectable
sql has several things you can use to
connect your database
um or a string which
is passed to your sql alchemy on sqlite
free connection
which is a special case here if you're
talking to sqlite database
all lava database type support for sql
icon
and writing a data frame back into the
database
um works with the two sql function
as with the read sql function it has two
main arguments
the first one is the name of the table
so you can't
be that flexible you have to write your
exactly one table
and the connection is the same connected
but as your test into
reads equal but it's pandas
so it has a huge set of flexibility and
the flexibility is exposed
by having additional keyword arguments
that you can use if needed
and don't have to use but that's also
the big power that you can expand
from a simple interface to much more
complex things which is
adding the bits you need the first thing
is
is the effects is parameter and
typically if you write q sql pandas also
has the magic that it
creates the table if it's not there and
takes care of
setting the right data type because you
know the data because they're using the
data frame
now the thing is it can create a table
but sometimes the table already exists
and then you need to tell pandas what it
should do
um the first case is the table exists
and you don't want
it actually change anything because you
have that one process that writes the
data
once and once it's written it should
state and it shouldn't change
so in that case if you want to tell
finders please fail please don't
change my database that's one golden
copy and
leave it as is sometimes you know
the latest version is the best routine
in that case you can calculate okay if
there's already some data inside
drop it and rewrite it with the latest
greatest things
otherwise if you have a workflow that's
running on a daily basis
and you have a table that spends all
time
um you just want to append the data
you're just running so you can find us
okay if there's already a table
leave the table as it is and just add my
data at the end
a big difference between pandas and a
database system
is that pandas has this column called
index
in a database you also have an index but
an index is not additional data it's um
it's a data structure used on the
background to give you faster access
to specific rows beta's database
can pre-compute some data structures
that have it
point faster to things easier to find
out where something's lying on disk
and panda has an index is an additional
column it's a special magical column
which gives names to rows the simplest
case that you have a range index
meaning go from zero to the number of
rows you have
um but it could also be something
different like actually
stringing it for that row and
you have to tell partners what it should
do with that and when it's inserting the
database because the database has no
notion of this index
the default behavior is that it will
insert an additional column called
index and story index there but you can
change that you can either set index
equals volts and just don't insert a
database
or you can if you keep the default true
you can set a label
and then insert the column to that label
um when you're inserting data especially
if you're using large amounts of data
you can tell pandas with the chunks of
parameter to insert layers over there at
once
this either has to be a bit of um not
overwhelming your database system or not
overwhelming
um your python purpose because
um inserting apprentice is not as
efficient as it can be that's why i'm
making this talk
but one of the problems is that in the
process of inserting to the database
we creating a lot of um temporary data
structures in python
that take up memory and if you do it
junk wise
um the memory peak will be lower so if
your machine is quite limited by memory
using smaller junk size may cost you
more time
but it also gives you the benefit that
you need less rap but in some cases
that's
quite a good trade-off
we have a data frame and each column
data frame has a data type
and we can use that um to bring set with
that
into the database um
but sometimes you have different data
types in your database because
pandas knows one day time it has a
one-day time 64
nanosecond precision actually your
database
knows a lot more daytime types depending
on
which database you're using there could
be over 10 or 20 data data
types and to actually tell pandas what
is the right one to use you can supply
it here because guessing is not possible
if you have 20 options
and the last one is the metal parameter
pandas does a lot of cool magic in the
two sequel function
like looking is the table already there
if not infer the data direction of the
data frame you select the correct
matching data types the databases create
a table and so on
but inserting to the database can be
optimized
and pandas provides a sql function
already a book
called method where you can say by
callable that gets the
um the name of a table gets a connection
and it gets an iterator over the rows of
the data frame
and you can insert with that into the
database you can use that to speed up
things especially for postgres
um but it sadly only gives you the
iterator of the data frame rows it
doesn't give you the exact data frame
and
making it not as good as it needs to be
to
do the optimizations we're doing later
so
this is when we can hook in today but it
doesn't provide a perfect
interface yet
now what i've skipped over a bit
beforehand was um
sql alchemy um i told you there's a
sequel i can be connectable
um but sql icon is actually
the main part of doing the magic here
it's a python toolkit that you can
connect to
very vast amount of databases supporting
sql
and it gives you a uniform interface for
that
meaning if you want to get metadata of a
table in your database
you can just use sql ip and get a meta
object of the table
right in plain python and for every
database that's out there and has to be
foreign
someone's written the clue code that
connects
the sql icon api to this special
sql dialect for getting the metadata of
the table
that's actually one where nearly every
database is different from another
database
and but we have this one uniform api and
it also gives you the ability to
um connect to every database to using
one uniform
interface and there's also a thing
called your object relational method
object relationship gives you the thing
that you can write to find a python
object with attributes
and connect it to a database table
that gives you transparent like if you
save this object or make changes to that
you can see the changes directly in the
database that's the thing we're not
using here
but what we need in partners is
the metadata layer so that we can find
out which tables are there what is the
schema name
and the engine interface which allows us
to connect
to all these databases supporting sql id
using the same interface
and due to the magic what is done in
these sql items drivers for the
databases
pandas doesn't actually know any
specifics about the database besides
for sql life and so every database that
you want to use on pandas only sql item
support doesn't need anything specific
for paragraphs
that means that panda does not actually
have so much sql code
for your support that's a really nice
thing
because if you want to look um what's
inside working with pandas
um it's mainly delegated to sql icon
and to find it out um a good idea is to
start a postgraduate instance locally
um you can do that by running a docker
container
that's the thing that works like this
command works on really a really nice
system if docker installed and it also
also works on a mac
and we can then use sql icon
to connect to that um that's an easy way
how do you
get a locally set up database instance
there various other ways and if you do
it in production also
they're much much better ways than doing
that but just for getting up and running
for this talk
this is quite a nice thing
and once we have now set up a new fresh
database instance
there's no data inside so we're going to
insert some
dummy data but at least take care that
we cover like the two regular data types
we're going to use
i'm skipping over day times here they
work too but
as i well before there's so many types
we don't need to get into complexity in
this simple example
to get that into the database we can
direct the user to sql function
we push the data into the test table
table
and use the connection we used from
customers database
um i'm using here efix replace because
this is my test code just to show a few
things and i
just always want the table to be exactly
the data frame i have
but i want to be able to execute the
code of not like
so we're just going to replace what's
there
to then see what's inside we can use the
plain sqlite interface
we can give it the select stuff from
test table command
and sql which will just fetch all data
which is inside
that returns the sql i can be resold and
we can fetch that
and then we get the typical python
interface of the database result
which is a list of rows and each row of
the database table
is presented as a total um
that's if you want to iterate over the
tail a nice data structure
but actually it's not the thing we need
in parallel
because appenders will not actually want
to have a list of rows we want to have a
list of columns
we want to have names we want to have
every
value of a column in a numpy array with
a fixed d
type so this looks okay
we know it's the data we inserted but
it's not a shape we want to have it
and therefore we can use the pandas
v-sql function
read sequel function can execute the
same query
also use the engine but it will return
for us
a data frame and here you already see
that we inserted the data with pandas
because we got four columns
and we have the special index column
which we didn't actually
see now the airframe but it's there in
every data frame because we create a
data frame with default index rage index
but if we fetch it again pandas has no
notion of knowing that
the column that is called index actually
the kind of index it has inserted before
because it can't store this anywhere so
this information is lost we can now
do reset index and use index column as
an index
we can deport and use that as it is here
or we can just drop it
but that's depending on how much of the
use is the index for unity
and now the important bit is how does it
actually work inside
and read sql the first thing it does
it actually delegates everything it does
to a class called sql database sql
database is the internal
pandas class which does the
talking to the sql alchemy interface
and reading data it's actually not so
much code
and it would execute the sql query you
gave it with sql alchemy
and sql item result has a property
called keys which you can
ask and it will give you the names of
the columns
um and depending whether you use the
chunk size parameter or not
um it will just call result.patch all
and get a list of rows as we got in the
previous example
and fetch that into the local process
um and pandas has a custom constructor
for
um a list of rows it's called this is
the from records constructor
and we call it with the rows and the
name of the columns
i said before pen has a lot of magic in
his keyword arguments
and he has also done a bit of this match
that happens afterwards once it's landed
in a data frame
some databases return dates as strings
we can pass them here
and also we can tell and as we do the
thing you told it to do with the index
column
set it drop it or do something else
basically we're delegating most of the
complicated work like
speaking the different dialects to a
database to sql iq
and it's not done
and the other way around
the sql statement is simpler but what we
do is actually more tricky
because we need to first check is the
target table already existing
if not what is our strategy
what would we do um typically we're not
existing we would
call a create table we tell sql alchemy
the name of the table and the data types
we want and sql item we will then
use its translation api to translate it
to a sql statement delete the database
we create a table and afterwards we'll
insert that table
into the database by using a list of
troubles per row
and that's done by just converting the
dataset back to its list of tools
um because sql i can mean a
general python db api has no notion of
kind of
a frame so we came back to name python
objects
and that's actually the main reason why
it's slow
um i'm going to show you some benchmarks
later
but now i'm actually going to first give
you
the theory why it actually is slow and
it's also the same thing right nice as
fast or why not perhaps fast
when you look at a structure of a python
list it's really flexible it's really
easy to use
but the flexibility it gives you also
comes with a cost
and python everything is an object and
that means
for every exiting everything
when you look at an object python
processor look at this object what kind
of object is
it needs to store for each object a
header where it knows the type
and what views it has and when we know
the fields
for a list we know it has a certain
length
and it has a list of memory pointers to
all of its items
so we want to access an item we go to
the python object see it's a list
we look at it with items we see a memory
pointer at the memory point it has the
location
of another python object which we then
can access
we also have a header and can look
inside of it and see oh it's an integer
so i have a byte of data and i will read
that
and have done my integer data for the
next element
list we have to go back to the items
list because it has a different memory
across a maybe totally different
location in memory
so we then go through the same thing
see the object is at that location see
it's an
integer so we read an x85 and have an
image
another array has the simple constraint
that
it assumes that everything in this array
is of the same data type
if we have an editor array we have one
python object with the header telling us
it's an amp array
this is the size and the data is located
here
and if you look at the data it's not a
list memory pointers
pointing to other databases but it's
actually directly the data meaning that
if you want to get the first value you
go into data and just pick the first one
right
that's eight bytes of an integer and the
next one is the next thing
that means that you have less overhead
indexes in these things
and it's not just the two jumps you
you got rid of but only have one memory
charm
from the object to the actual content
but it also means that if you want to
read the second value you just
read the next eight bytes and luckily if
you access memory in your computer
if you read the first value it will
already fetch like 64 kilobytes or so
and out of memory into your cpu caches
and then you can read the next 64 bytes
really fast the next 128 bytes of that
row
with the semi-first and so on but it
will be much much faster
than accessing just any other random
object in memory
and as long as you keep your data and
numpy race it's really efficient
it's you have the limitation that
everything needs to be of the same size
it's not easily appendable like another
python list but it's also
a bit of aspect given you can live with
these constraints
and that's also a big difference why
pandas read sequel isn't as fast as it
could
be because we're passing sql query to
sql alchemy
secret alchemy fetches python objects
for us
and then we take these python object to
create a data frame but if you have a
million rows with 50 columns we will
create 50 million python object
in sql icon and we'll directly get rid
of them again when we create a data
frame because we don't need python
objects that we use something much more
efficient
um to show you the overhead um
actually i'm going to use packet files
because this is like the most efficient
way how you can
store data on this um
because in the database world you have
actually two components that make it
pretty costly
it's the time it takes to execute on the
database
and the time it takes you to basically
site into a data frame
um i'm only talking here and just talk
about how long it takes to actually
start
but as these two components are involved
we're
going to skip the the path where we talk
about
the time it takes to fetch it
from the database or the time takes the
computer group
and reading that the packet file we can
either select really directly into
packet which takes
two to three seconds or we can
use the pyro interface read it into an
error table
convert it into a python dictionary
which is
like the huge amount of python objects
and then convert it directly back to a
data frame
in both cases we get the exact same data
frame but in one we don't construct any
intermediate python objects
and the second one we construct like
millions of intermediate python objects
and we see the difference that the
second one takes up to three minutes the
first one takes three seconds
it makes a really huge difference if you
have the same difference in
actually the database
and this likely takes us to the point
how do we get it fast
and the obvious thing is here we just
want to get rid of this intermediate
python objects
we either want to fetch directly into a
data frame
or some efficient structure which can be
converted
easily to a data frame which doesn't
cost that so much in conversion
and for that one of the typical standard
apis
people use to access the database is
odbc
it's a standard api set in cc plus plus
how you connect to database given some
apis this is like the sql alchemy
metadata interface in of the native
world
the true purple language for that the
most well known is pi
odbc it's the most mature
former colleague of mine has written
2dbc which
does the same things as pi ovc but with
some performance optimizations inside so
it's like
20 faster um
we're actually interested in the error
support to bdbc because that's the thing
where it has a different api and power
ubc because pilot pc and two we see
both implement the path 249 db
api 2 which gives you a list
of rows in python but curabc also
supports
fetching into an error table arrow
is an open source project which defines
a uniform memory format for calling my
data in
a lot of languages there are over times
of our language currently
and data format looks quite similar to a
data frame and for us
importantly um you can access error
cables from c plus plus and from python
and in 2vdc we have support for fetching
data from odbc
into arrow memory and then passing just
a pointer to the error cable to python
and arrow has support for really really
fast conversion from error to pandas
which gives us a bit of overhead
but it's like 100 times smaller than the
overhead it would take to convert from
python objects to pandas
and this is one of the tricks we can use
to um
get faster access to databases that have
a decent ovc trainer
um databases with a decent odbc driver
are ms sql
and access all here in both cases
there's a talk of michelle kunich the
original offer which shows that you can
get a free to fart and speed up
um using this arrow interface into abc
compared to
using the sql item interface
and as read sql is using
um there are databases like postgres um
they have an odbc interface
that's working but actually not so good
for a big result set
that's a case where you could use that
approach you maybe get like a
ten percent increase in performance over
the sql ip interface
but in some cases you don't even get one
because the driver lbc itself isn't that
performant
and that's where you need to you do
different approaches
2bdbc is nice because it has it can
retrofit this performance to existing
drivers
but you still have the conversion in
your driver you can fetch again in odbc
you convert it to error
and you convert it to pandas um that
means a system overhead
snowflake actually is one of the nice
modern databases
um that comes with a simple json
interface that is readable in every
language with all dependencies
but it also has the support that
actually the database server itself
can give you the result set as error
meaning the client
matches the error data structure and
doesn't need to convert its results or
so into error
for converting into partner but directly
fetches an error
and only destiny to do the error
companies conversion
and the only error dependence conversion
is really really fast
um so that fetching result from the
database
isn't actually taking that much effort
um
over the website they have a benchmark
where they improve their drivers using
aero
um they did some benchmarks about how um
the drivers on the back end of the
stable api got faster
and then how much faster they got
conversion to pandas
when they didn't use the standard python
api but um
pass the error results directly to
pandas and
they see a speedo times 10. and i'm
actually also using that driver and the
time can speed up is actually what i'm
also seeing so
this is really nice and this is what you
get if you
um get rid of all these transformations
in between and have like a tiny error
competitors version
which is even in some cases zero copy
these are two typical cases um how you
generally can make it faster
jdbc is the java world equivalent of
odbc
i've written a blog post about that it's
here on the slide so that you know how
it works
it's quite complicated
so i'm not going to go into detail here
the important thing is um
you can use that to fetch things on the
java side you get arrow back
and then you get a reference to the jvm
memory and can convert it directly to
pandas
it takes a lot of awful amount of time
to set this up
because it depends on how your drivers
are stored you need to get a jar for the
right
place um but if you're using a database
that only has decent jdbc drivers and
nothing else
actually it's worth getting that effort
because in my simple
i already had a 100 over 100 times speed
up
so spending four hours and getting that
setup
it may well be worth the effort it
will be complicated but it could pay off
you quite a bit um as i said
before postgres um doesn't have a
good odbc driver postgres has a
copy interface which can give you the
result as a csv
or as postgres binary format
you can use that this is for the cc
output there's even example independence
documentation
to use the binary format and
you can get a bit of more performance i
may open source something in future
um it's a bit more tricky but it also
gives you a bit more performance
that was now example how you can get it
fast with four different interfaces
um we would like to have this actually
as part of kind of three sql mainly
because
if you look at it kind of receive it
with a simple api
two parameters and you create an engine
sql iphone
qbc you need a connection you need a
cursor and then you need to call federal
error to pandas
um also not that complicated
and the thing is coming in when you look
at snowflake
it's doing nearly the same thing but
it's not exactly the same thing so it's
not like you need to have
a similar but different approach
for jdbc it's much more complicated
um this is the most simple form you can
get and it's quite quite
dense what we're doing here um
prosperous is even more complicated so
the thing is
you need for every database you need a
custom solution how to connect to it
and you need to know what actually the
parameters are and if you want to
support more than one database in your
code
you need a lot of things so the nice
thing would be
get the performance we get with using
these custom interfaces but have it in
paradise
and for that um
we actually want to have something and
find us one thing we could use here is
that actually
you can ask the item for the underlying
connection like in my case if i call
on a postgres connection i go to raw
connection i get the cycle pg class back
um and then i can maybe do something
special on that
pandas because i don't actually want
that my users learn new api i just want
them
install this package maybe use this
keyword and you get performance
what single keyword would be nice by
calling it engine equals two vbc
and then still use pi type appenders to
reach equal
another product would be that kindness
defines the database engine class
and says here are three different
methods just
get an airframe and a table name insert
it and you have a way around really
read it but kindness is only giving you
insertion setting up table names data
heads so on
finance can handle for uw that's done in
sql to me
and performance there is no issue um
because creating a table is not
depending on the size of your data
but it's the same performance
if you insert one drawer or if you're
inserting multiple rows and i can write
this one implementation give it a name
and call find out beats equal and
in this case engineering was faster
function that just works
discussions for that uh on the planet's
issue tracker if you have
better ideas please weigh in i'm maybe
going to do an implementation of that
but getting into some support will make
it faster
that was all my talk and i hope you got
a grip
that pandas and sql database actually
work quite well together
if performance of larger results that
isn't issued for you
by showing you some ways how to invest
some time but get it faster nowadays
and hopefully you you're all looking
forward for
the future where it's not so complicated
anymore but can just select an engine
and pandas and get the performance
you get with more complicated treats
thanks for watching and for everyone
who's at a conference in the q a session
now is your time breaking ask questions
otherwise
ask them on twitter and i will try to
answer them